I think a lot of leaders don't know what
their job is when we're very Junior in
our careers our companies give us tons
of training to do our jobs so that we'll
be good at our jobs obviously and some
of us even get Advanced degrees so that
we'll be good at our jobs and if you're
good at your job you get promoted to a
position where you're now responsible
for the people who do the job you used
to do but we give you no education on
how to lead so we just expect people to
know how to lead and give them no
education I wouldn't go see a doctor
who's had no education why would I
follow a leader who's had no education
and so what happens is is um because
you've given me no you haven't even
given me a definition of what a leader
is you just told me I'm in charge well
that just makes you an authority not a
leader leadership is the awesome
responsibility to see those around us
rise your job is no longer to do the job
your job is to see those around you be
better at the job than you were based on
all that amazing experience you had it's
a completely different skill set and so
what you find is a lot of people are
insecure so they're going to either
micromanage or tell you what to do cuz I
actually do know how to do your job
better it's what got me promoted um and
we're very uncomfortable with the fact
that somebody might not like I had to do
it that way you're going to have to do
it that I had to do my five years you're
there's no way you're going to go faster
if I've got somebody who's smart and
talented going faster than me I want to
Foster that what makes me the leader is
that I'm going to build the best team
around me and the reason they'll follow
me and they're not going to try and uh
stab me in the back is because they see
me offering that growth they see me
providing that Circle of safety they see
me offering them uh an ear for them when
they're when they're struggling or when
they need help they I'm regulating when
to jump in and help and when to let them
figure it out themselves and they know
like a parent that I'm always there to
support uh and we aren't a telling
leaders what their role is which is to
lead people and two we're not educating
leaders how to lead and so we're going
to get we're going to get leaders who
are going to stifle brilliant young
minds because of our own insecurities
okay